I had a chance to talk to
president-elect Trump last night about
3:30 in the morning I think it was to
congratulate him on winning the election
and I had a chance to invite him to come
to the White House tomorrow to talk
about making sure that there is a
successful transition between our
presidencies now it is no secret that
the president-elect and I have some
pretty significant differences but
remember eight years ago President Bush
and I had some pretty significant
differences but President Bush's team
could not have been more professional or
more gracious in making sure we had a
smooth transition so that we could hit
the ground running and one thing you
realized quickly in this job is that the
presidency and the vice presidency is
bigger than any of us so I have
instructed my team to follow the example
that President Bush's team set eight
years ago and work as hard as we can to
make sure that this is a successful
transition for the president-elect
because peaceful transition of power is
one of the hallmarks of our democracy
and over the next few months we are
going to show that to the world I also
had a chance last night to speak with
Secretary Clinton and I just had a
chance to hear her remarks I could not
be prouder of her she has lived an
extraordinary life of public service she
was a great first lady she was an
outstanding Senator for the state of New
York and she could not have been a
better Secretary of State I'm proud of
her a lot of Americans look up to her
her candidacy and nomination was
historic and sends a message to our
daughters all across the country that
they can achieve at the highest levels
of politics and I'm absolutely confident
that she and President Clinton will
continue to do great work for people
here in the United States and all around
the world now everybody is sad when
their side loses an election
but the day after we have to remember
that we're actually all on one team
this is an intramural scrimmage we're
not Democrats first we're not
Republicans first we are Americans first
we're Patriots first we all what want
what's best for this country that's what
I heard mr. Trump's remarks last night
that's what I heard when I spoke to him
directly and I was hardened by that
that's what the country needs a sense of
unity a sense of inclusion a respect for
our institutions our way of life rule of
law and respect for each other I hope
that he maintains that spirit throughout
this transition and I certainly hope
that's how his presidency has a chance
to begin I also told my team today to
keep their heads up because the
remarkable work that they have done
day-in day-out
often without a lot of fanfare often
with a lot of a lot of attention work
and agencies work in obscure areas of
policy that make government run better
and make it more responsive and make it
more efficient and make it more service
friendly so that it's actually helping
more people that remarkable work has
left the next president with a stronger
better country than the one that existed
eight years ago so win or lose in this
election that was always our mission
that was our mission from day one and
everyone on my team should be
extraordinarily proud of everything that
they have done
and so should all the Americans that
I've had a chance to meet all across
this country
who do the hard work of building on that
progress every single day teachers and
schools doctors and ER clinic small
businesses putting their all into
starting something up making sure
they're treating their employees well
all the important work that's done by
moms and dads and families and
congregations in every state the work of
perfecting this union so this was a long
and hard-fought campaign a lot of our
fellow Americans are exultant today a
lot of Americans are less so but that's
the nature of campaigns that's the
nature of democracy it is hard and
sometimes contentious and noisy it's not
always inspiring but to the young people
who got into politics for the first time
and maybe disappointed by the results I
just want you to know you have to stay
encouraged don't get cynical don't ever
think you can't make a difference the
Secretary Clinton said this morning
fighting for what is right is worth it
sometimes you lose an argument sometimes
you lose an election you know the path
that this country has taken has never
been a straight line we zig and zag and
sometimes we move in ways that some
people think is forward and others think
is moving back and that's okay I've lost
elections before Joe hasn't but
you know so I've been I've been searched
are you beat me badly that's the way
politics works sometimes we we try
really hard to persuade people that
we're right and then people vote and
then if we lose we learn from our
mistakes we do some reflection we like
our wounds we brush ourselves off we get
back in the arena we go at it we try
even harder the next time the point
though is is that we all go forward with
the presumption of good faith in our
fellow citizens because that presumption
of good faith is essential to a vibrant
and functioning democracy that's how
this country has moved forward for 240
years that's how we've pushed boundaries
and promoted freedom around the world
that's how we've expanded the rights of
our founding to reach all of our
citizens it's how we have come this far
and that's why I'm confident that this
incredible journey that we are on as
Americans will go on and I'm looking
forward to doing everything that I can
to make sure that the next president is
successful in that I've said before I
think of this job as being a relay
runner you take the baton you run your
best race and hopefully by the time you
hand it off you're a little further
ahead you've made a little progress and
I can say that we've done that and I
want to make sure that handoff is well
executed because ultimately we're all on
the same team all right thank you very
much everybody
[Applause]